Bonjour!
Et bienvenue dans ce nouvel épisode dont
la grande qualité, j'espère, vous fera oublier
le temps que j'ai mis à le sortir.
Malheureusement j'ai perdu quelques données
relatives à Chroniques de Prof lorsque quelqu'un
a malencontreusement embarqué mon ordinateur
avec lui alors que je prenais le train.
Il s'est bien fait avoir, j'avais encore vista.
J'ai donc décidé de faire simple pour cette
fois et j'ai repris un sujet développé dans
ce mémoire.
Que j'ai écrit.
Ça aide, au moins, je connais bien le sujet.
-Oui enfin ça fait des jours que tu me parles
des astrologues en terme de croyance, de superstition...
L'astrologie est une science, tu sais!
-Non! L'astronomie est une science, l'astrologie
repose sur des croyances, mais c'est vrai
qu'à ton époque on ne faisait pas la différence!
Vous savez probablement ce que sont les astrologues,
mais qu'est-ce que les astrologues de cour?
Eh bien les grands princes, et ducs de France
et d'autres royaumes disposaient de tout un
tas de personnages dans leur cour afin de
les servir, des cuisiniers, barbiers, médecins,
écuyers...
On parle aussi de l' «hôtel princier»
pour désigner tout l'ensemble de ce personnel.
Je pourrais faire une vidéo là-dessus d'ailleurs...
-Idée n°376...
-Parmi eux pouvaient se trouver des astrologues,
dont le rôle était de produire des prédictions
et tout un tas d'autres documents pour aider
leur prince.
Certains se trouvaient présents toute l'année
à la cour, d'autres pouvaient être appelés
occasionnellement, et d'autres encore n'avaient
rien à voir avec la choucroute mais décidaient
de réaliser une prédiction pour un prince
afin de se mettre en avant.
Eh regardez, j'ai écrit une super prédiction
sur vous! Il va vous arriver que des bonnes
choses.
Sinon, vous embauchez?
L'exemple le plus connu d'astrologue est Michel
de Nostredame, que vous connaissez sous le
nom de Nostradamus et qui était pensionné
à la cour de Catherine de Médicis au XVIe
siècle.
A son service, il a réalisé de nombreuses
prophéties que certain s'amusent encore à
interpréter de nos jours.
Les astrologues dont je vais vous parler datent
plutôt du Xve siècle.
Mais comme Nostradamus, ils étaient pour
la plupart des personnes instruites, bacheliers
voire maîtres en médecine ou dans d'autres
disciplines scientifiques.
Parce que pour eux, du moins en théorie,
l'astrologie était une science très précise!
Il fallait observer les positions des étoiles,
des constellations, connaître des tas de
méthodes de calcul compliquées pour réaliser
leurs prédictions.
-Ah tu vois, quand je te disais que c'était
scientifique!
-Oui, enfin dans les faits, on avait aussi
beaucoup de profiteurs.
Il était facile de dire que tel roi allait
mourir dans l'année, par exemple, si on savait
qu'il était malade, ou qui allait l'emporter
sur telle bataille quand on connaissait les
rapports de force.
Du coup il est fort probable que beaucoup
d'astrologues, sur une base scientifique,
réalisent leurs prédictions en restant assez
vagues et en cherchant à plaire à la personne
à qui elles étaient destinées.
Un peu comme les horoscopes d'aujourd'hui,
en fait.
A d'autres moments, les astrologues font carrément
œuvre de propagande au service de leur prince.
Par exemple, Jean de Vésale, au service du
duc Charles le Téméraire, réalise une prédiction
d'après l'observation d'une comète.
Pour tous les astrologues, les comètes sont
un mauvais présage, et les autres astrologues
qui ont observé cette comète ont déclaré
qu'elle était placée dans le signe de la
Balance, qui est celui de Charles le Téméraire,
et que ça sentait donc le roussi pour lui.
Jean de Vésale décide que pas du tout, cette
comète est dans le signe de la Vierge, et
c'est donc Louis XI, l'ennemi de Charles le
Téméraire, qui aura chaud aux fesses.
Non mais.
« Et il y aura des maladies, des mortalités,
des famines, la mort d'enfants en bas âge
et l'avortement
des femmes grosses.
Il y aura des tonnerres et des éclairs, des
incendies de moissons et beaucoup de
rois et de grands tomberont du rang qu'ils
occupent.
»
Si certains astrologues croyaient dur comme
fer en ce qu'ils faisaient, ce n'était donc
probablement pas le cas de tous.
-Tu ruine toutes mes croyances, tu le sais
ça?
Maintenant nous allons nous intéresser aux
types de documents que produisaient les astrologues!
J'ai déjà parlé des prédictions qu'ils
pouvaient faire à l'occasion, comme Nostradamus,
et qui étaient ce qui se rapproche le plus
d'oeuvres de propagande.
Par exemple une prédiction que j'aime beaucoup
déclare que la lignée des ducs de Bourgogne
sera merveilleuse, étonnante, épatante,
et l'astrologue le sait bien parce qu'il a
connu personnellement Jean sans Peur, ce grand
homme!
Il prédit que ses quatre héritiers mâles
feront de grandes choses, gagneront leurs
batailles, etc.
Sauf qu'en analysant le texte on se rend compte
que la prédiction est bien trop précise,
et que l'auteur n'a pas pu naître à la date
qu'il prétend.
En réalité elle a été écrite au début
du XVIe siècle, à l'époque du fameux quatrième
héritier mâle qui n'est autre que Charles
Quint et c'est donc une fausse prophétie
visant à le mettre en valeur.
-T'arrives à déchiffrer ça toi?
-La paléographie, ça sert pas à grand chose
dans la vie de tous les jours, mais c'est
vachement cool.
Les astrologues réalisaient aussi des prédictions
annuelles, qui expliquaient le déroulement
de l'année à venir: le temps qu'il fera,
la qualité des récoltes, s'il y aura des
maladies, des guerres, etc.
-May sera pour la première partie beau raisonnablement
et sera en aucuns jours chaud et vent du mydi
ou d'occident et est possible que apres aucuns
chauds soit parfois tonnerre, tempête et
vent! Et nous fêterons la saint Fernand.
-Un autre type de prédiction que j'aime beaucoup
est l'almanach annuel.
Dans un almanach annuel, l'astrologue dresse
un calendrier accompagné des jours les plus
propices, d'après la position des astres,
pour accomplir telle ou telle action.
Ce sont donc des œuvres beaucoup plus scientifiques
que les prédictions, et qui se rapprochent
du fait que les astrologues sont aussi médecins
puisqu'on y retrouve les jours propices aux
saignées par exemple.
Par exemple dans cet almanach, qui est le
plus détaillé que je possède, l'astrologue
montre quels jours sont propices pour envoyer
des messages, attaquer une ville, commencer
une guerre ou faire la paix, acheter des armes,
se laver, se couper les cheveux ou les ongles.
Donc si en octobre 1426 on veut se venger
de ses ennemis, c'est le jour 1, celui qu'on
retient.
Ainsi le seigneur sait comment organiser toute
son année! Bien sûr ce sont des recommandations
sur les jours les plus favorables, et le prince
qui reçoit cet almanach n'est pas obligé
de les respecter à la lettre.
Ça serait vite le bordel...
« Alors, le 28 janvier j'achète des chevaux,
j'en ai déjà plein mes écuries mais c'est
le ciel qui le dit, le 3 mars je déclare
une guerre...
Merde, mais j'ai pas d'ennemis moi...
Bon, je vais bien trouver.
Ah mais deux jours après il faut que je déclare
la paix, ça va être compliqué...
Et quand est-ce que je peux me couper les
ongles? Le 2 mai?! C'est dans 5 mois!
»
D'autres almanachs sont beaucoup moins détaillés
et se contentent de montrer les jours favorables
aux saignées, ce sont les petits «f»
que vous voyez, avec plusieurs f quand c'est
le jour où on peut se saigner à la folie!
Et dans la colonne à côté, les petits «l»
correspondent aux jours favorables pour prendre...
Des laxatifs.
Dans la vie d'un duc, on n'a pas le temps
de se laisser aller.
Il y a deux types de journées.
Celle où on se fait saigner, et celle où
on prend des laxatifs.
Il existe enfin un autre type de production
des astrologues: le carré astrologique,
qui comporte des signes du zodiaque et des
chiffres...
Et qui est censé éclairer le futur d'une
personne, ici Charles le Téméraire et Marie
de Bourgogne, à partir de la position des
astres à une date précise: souvent, sa
date de naissance ou son anniversaire.
Mais pour ça, encore faut-il connaître la
date de naissance exacte, à la seconde près,
de la personne dont on veut faire l'horoscope!
La plupart des princes faisaient donc attention
à noter la date exacte de la naissance de
leur héritier, mais pour ceux qui ne s'intéressaient
pas trop à l'astrologie, ça leur passait
un peu au dessus.
-Mais du coup ils ne pouvaient pas connaître
leur destin!
-Eh oui, et c'est le problème que connaît
le roi Charles VII qui, ironie du sort, adore
l'astrologie! Mais son père n'a pas pensé
à noter sa date de naissance exacte, certains
astrologues considéreront qu'il est d'un
certain ascendant, d'autres ne seront pas
d'accord...
Si les astrologues s'en tiennent à la science
ils ne peuvent donc pas réaliser de prédictions,
d'almanachs ou d'horoscopes pour ce roi.
Mais ils le font quand même et tant pis s'ils
trichent un peu, parce que ça rapporte.
Les astrologues de cour avaient donc pas mal
de travail et servaient même de conseillers
aux princes.
Ils leurs disaient si la décision qu'ils
s'apprêtaient à prendre était bonne ou
non, ou encore quel type ou couleur de vêtement
il convenait de porter selon les jours toujours
d'après l'observation du ciel.
On a dit pas de rose le jeudi!
Certains princes y croyaient vraiment, d'autres
étaient plus sceptiques mais préféraient
écouter ce qu'ils avaient à dire, dans le
doute, et d'autres n'y croyaient pas trop.
Il y avait assez peu de critiques à l'encontre
des astrologues et l'Eglise les acceptait:
ceux qui étaient le plus condamnés étaient
les devineurs, en gros, ceux qui faisaient
leurs prédictions à partir d'autre chose
que l'observation des étoiles: la géomancie
par exemple, la nécromancie, et de manière
générale tout ce qui ressemblait un peu
trop à de la sorcellerie.
Voilà, j'espère que cette vidéo vous a
plu, en tout cas j'avais dans l'idée d'en
faire une sur ce thème depuis le début.
Si ce thème vous a intéressés, outre mon
mémoire il existe un très bon livre de Maxime
Préaud sur le sujet, «les astrologues
à la fin du Moyen-Âge».
Vous pouvez me retrouver sur facebook, le
lien est dans la description, vous abonner
et continuer de me suggérer des thèmes pour
de prochaines vidéos.
Merci d'avoir regardé!